[Musik]
der tag des siegels 75 jahre nach
kriegsende gedenken russland und andere
ehemalige sowjetrepubliken ihre
millionen opfer billiglohn arbeiter in
der fleischindustrie nach dem corner aus
buer in mehreren schlachthöfen fordern
gewerkschaften und politiker
grundlegende änderungen mit ihnen
startete der rock'n roll musik legende
little richard stirbt im alter von 87
jahren
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten am samstag dem 9 mai dem
tag der für die länder der ehemaligen
sowjetunion das ende des weltkriegs
markiert russland feiert seinen sieg
über nazi-deutschland erst heute
denn als die deutsche wehrmacht
schließlich kapitulierte war in russland
schon der neunte mai angebrochen
den wollte präsident putin zum
bedeutenden jubiläum eigentlich auch
besonders prominent begehen
kein land war ja so sehr betroffen vom
zweiten weltkrieg wie die damalige
sowjetunion 27 millionen tote fast jedes
zweite opfer kam von dort viele regionen
wurden komplett zerstört
der neunte mai der sieg über hitler
deutschland ist deshalb der bedeutendste
nicht kirchliche feiertag in russland
immer in szene gesetzt mit einer großen
militärparade
doch die für dieses jahr aus für begann
berichtet rosen am grab des unbekannten
soldaten verneigung vor den 27 millionen
opfern die der sieg über den
nationalsozialismus in der sowjetunion
forderte präsident putin appellierte an
die geschlossenheit seines volkes
[Musik]
das ist unsere erinnerung und unser
stolz die geschichte unseres landes die
geschichte jeder familie der teil
unserer seele der uns von unseren vätern
müttern großmüttern und großmüttern
verehrt wurde
stellvertretend für jedes jahr seit dem
ende des krieges fliegen 75 militär
flugzeuge und hubschrauber über den
roten platz die große parade mit der
moskau an diesem tag sonst sich selbst
und der welt seine militärische stärke
demonstriert ist wegen corona verschoben
ganz anders in belarus auch weißrussland
genannt tausende soldaten marschieren
durch die hauptstadt minsk
die ex-sowjetrepublik litt besonders
unter den nazis der neunte mai sei daher
heilig sagt präsident lukaschenko vor
dicht an dicht sitzenden veteranen
ich gratuliere ihnen zum tag des sieges
das kit 19 auch in seinem land grassiert
ignoriert lukaschenko bereits seit
wochen nun also hält belarus die einzige
große militärparade inmitten der
pandemie ab stolz unter den zuschauern
es ist eine pflicht für jeden an der
parade teilzunehmen egal was ist dieser
sieg hat uns so viel mühe gekostet so
viele verluste in moskau hingegen fällt
das gedenken am 75 jahrestag weit
kleiner aus als geplant und wird gerade
dadurch besonders würde voll und jetzt
zum großen thema corona die krise bringt
ja ein altes problem wieder ans licht
die arbeitsverhältnisse in der
fleischindustrie in mindestens zwei
betrieben grassiert das virus und
beobachter sind sicher
das liegt an der unterbringung der
arbeit oft kommen sie aus osteuropa
werden schlecht bezahlt und wohnen den
ausgemusterten kasernen auf engstem raum
thomas garcia und carsten edinger
berichten tiere schlachten tägliches
geschäft nun erstmal nicht mehr
der betrieb in bad bramstedt
schleswig-holstein eingestellt die
arbeiter in quarantäne und allzu nah
beieinander wie in ihren engen
unterkünften 119 sind infiziert einige
zeigen symptome
kaum raum auch für die beschäftigten bei
westfleisch großfeld nrw in kleinbussen
pendelten sie zwischen arbeits- und
schlafstätte das werk nun ebenfalls
nicht wenige verpacken noch waren und
machen sich sorgen
180 infizierte sind es hier vermeidbare
fälle sagt ein gewerkschafter und
beobachter lange sei bekannt dass hier
osteuropäische arbeitnehmer hin kommt
die zum teil katastrophal untergebracht
sind da ist im prinzip nichts passiert
es habe kontrollen gegeben sagt der
landkreis die schlaf- und wohnsituation
organisiere man nun neu das ist auch
vorgesehen dass umbelegung stattfinden
müssen also dass deutlich weniger in den
unterkünften sind stärkere kontrollen ab
jetzt gerade jetzt fordert der
arbeitsminister den letzten jahren sind
schon regeln verschärft worden gerade in
der fleischindustrie weil die sozialen
bedingungen unerträglich wurden aber die
schärfsten gesetze nutzen nur dann wenn
sie von den ländern auch konsequent
kontrolliert und umgesetzt werden reicht
nicht so die grünen sie fordern
unternehmer verantwortlich zu machen
sie haben seltsame subunternehmer
geflechte und werkverträge und das muss
gesetzlich unterbunden werden übrigens
bereits ende april infizierten sich in
dieser fabrik baden württemberg mehr als
200 rumänen corona zeigt es krankt beim
arbeitsschutz in deutschland und nun der
blick auf die aktuellen infektionszahlen
in deutschland wichtig ist da die
entwicklung der täglichen
neuansteckungen und die liegt weiter
unter 1000 im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage steckten sich
930 menschen pro tag mit dem corona
virus an
insgesamt sind stand 18 uhr 30 mehr als
170.000 infektionen durch tests
bestätigt davon gelten 143 1300 als
genesen 7500 zehn menschen starben in
verbindung mit coop 19
wochenlang waren die restaurants wegen
corona geschlossen jetzt sollen sie nach
und nach wieder öffnen
den anfang machte heute mecklenburg
vorpommern doch es gibt strenge auflagen
unter anderem
diese einen mindestabstand von einem
meter fünfzig zwischen fremden gästen
tische gibt es für maximal sechs
personen und sie sollten vorab
reserviert werden
außerdem müssen gäste kontaktdaten
abgeben wie das alles gelingt berichtet
susanne seidel
es ist alles etwas anders als sonst das
service personal trägt maske die gäste
müssen ihre adressen hinterlassen alles
wird desinfiziert abstände eingehalten
dennoch genießen die besucher dieses
kaffees in schwerin die neue freiheit
wenn auch manche mit vorsicht was mir am
meisten gefehlt hat dass man auch mal
draußen sitzen kann kaffee trinken
ich genieße das ganz einfach heute man
sitzt draußen kann jetzt ein eis essen
oder kaffeetrinken wunderbar aber essen
gehen jetzt hier mittag oder abendessen
das würde ich jetzt nicht machen draußen
jahr ja auch mit einem gewissen abstand
aber ich habe es ja nur sehr vorsichtig
sein weil das corona ist ja noch nicht
vorbei
nach sieben langen wochen dürfen die
gastronomen in mecklenburg vorpommern
als erste wieder gäste bewirten die
erleichterung unter ihnen ist groß doch
um für den nötigen abstand zwischen den
besuchern zu sorgen gibt es nur noch
halb so viele tische weniger kunden
weniger einnahmen es reicht im moment
noch nicht ganz klar
und wenn es noch so weit an hält die
haben verluste die werden wir so schnell
nicht einfahren können jetzt hoffen alle
café und restaurant besitzer dass die
gäste auch kommen und nicht aus sorge
vor dem virus wegbleiben
in den anderen bundesländern öffnen die
restaurants etwas später doch shoppen
ist überall möglich
in hamburg waren die fußgängerzonen
heute jedenfalls knallvoll und an der
alster sorgten jogger spaziergänger und
radfahrer für drangvolle enge spricht
eigentlich noch jemand vom gebotenen
mindestabstand martin neeson hat sich in
hamburg um gesehen
endlich sie dürfen wieder ihre boote zu
wasser lassen
im hamburger segel club begann heute die
saison
zwei monate später als sonst und unter
strengen auflagen
die hat der verein vorsorglich überall
aufgehängt wir dürfen auf eine mann-frau
boten segeln und wir dürfen auch auf
zwei personen boden segeln das bedingt
allerdings sollen die einhaltung der
abstände oder eben familienangehörige
aus einem haushalt der grat zwischen
wieder gewonnenen freiheiten und
einhalten der abstandsregeln ist schmal
nicht nur beim joggen um die alster in
der hamburger innenstadt gefallen die
lockerungen nicht allen
welche bedenken habe ich der versteht
ist jetzt genau der richtige zeitpunkt
wollen unsere wirtschaft darunter
natürlich extrem leidet das ist
vielleicht noch ein bisschen zu früh ich
hat vielleicht noch ein monat gewartet
und dann bis man wirklich sicher ist
dass es langsam wieder okay es die angst
vor leichtsinn und einem erneuten
lockdown treibt auch die betreiber der
europa passage um in der einkaufsmeile
gelten masken pflicht strikte
abstandsregeln und das einwand straßen
prinzip trotz der lockerungen sind sie
von den kunden zahlen der folk oder zeit
heute noch weit entfernt
ein dritter touristen die sind heute
überhaupt nicht da wir haben einen hohen
anteil von denen menschen die beruflich
in der stadt arbeiten von denen sind ein
paar prozent dar weil die meisten sind
ja noch im home office und das macht
über 50 prozent aus die einfach heute
noch fehlen der wunsch nach einer
rückkehr zur normalität kollidiert mit
der angst vor dem wieder ansteigende
ansteckungsrate was geht und was geht
nicht in zeiten von corona in dieser
frage das richtige maß zu finden ist und
bleibt eine kunst die grünen und
tübingens grüner oberbürgermeister boris
palmer
das ist längst keine liebesbeziehung
mehr immer wieder war mit provokanten
äußerungen angeeckt zuletzt mit blick
auf corona und dem satz wir retten in
deutschland möglicherweise menschen die
in einem halben jahr sowieso tot wären
der landesvorstand fordert ihn zum
parteiaustritt auf was palmer aber
ablehnt die bundes partei sagt palmer
sprechen nur für sich ein
parteiausschluss sei zurzeit kein thema
in mehreren deutschen städten heute
proteste gegen korona beschränkungen
die demonstranten wollen mehr
freiheitsrechte während der pandemie und
raus aus dem block daun
allein in stuttgart waren es tausende
mit dabei auch verschwörungstheoretiker
rechtspopulisten und ins gegner
innenminister der länder sind alarmiert
und sehen hier den versuch von
extremisten die proteste zu kapern
eva schiller und sandra susanka
berichten
es ist eine mischung aus wut und sorge
die tausende menschen in stuttgart
vereint die korona maßnahmen der
regierung gehen den demonstranten zu
weit
was mich am allermeisten im moment ist
die diskussion über die impfpflicht
überhaupt für die ganze familie
behandelt wird finde ich so ein bisschen
überzogen dass ich mein ganzes land
gegen die wand fährt
83 millionen gesunde menschen in
quarantäne zu schicken oder wegzusperren
und die wirtschaft dazu ist es ja was
gab es noch überhaupt
neben diesen sorgen beobachten wir aber
auch rechte parolen plakate mit
verschwörungstheorien und treffen arzt
bodo schiffmann der im netz die
protestbewegung widerstand 20 20
gegründet hat wir haben seit 18 tagen
eine partei und wir sehen sie sich diese
bewegung die an gut es ist der wahnsinn
unser zdf faktencheck team hat die
fragwürdigen ansichten die der arzt
verbreitet analysiert was die
gefährlichkeit des virus angeht da
drückt er sich widersprüchlich aus
einerseits sagt er das virus ist
gefährlich und er wisse dass auch
andererseits sagt er dass seine so
gefährlich wie eine grippe
wir wissen dass es nicht stimmt weil es
gegen die influenza-viren eben
impfstoffe gibt und gegen das corona
virus noch nicht trotzdem verfangen
videos mit fake news mehr denn je
beobachtet psychologin pia lamberti die
zu verschwörungstheorien forscht wie
schnell der protest eskaliert zeigt sich
in berlin und so fürchtet der
verfassungsschutz das radikale kräfte
aber auch politische extremisten die
demonstrationen unterwandert
was ist fakt was ist fake die fakten
checker von zdf heute nehmen regelmäßig
aussagen rund und die korona krise unter
die lupe ihre ergebnisse finden sie
zusammengestellt in der zdf- heute- app
nach new york der stadt die so stark
unter corona leidet dort sorgt jetzt
eine entscheidung bei der uno für
schlagzeilen und einen eklat
die usa haben nämlich eine resolution
zur corona pandemie gestoppt wochenlang
hatten die 15 mitglieder des
sicherheitsrats ein entwurf beraten
in dem eine weltweite waffenruhe
gefordert wird un-generalsekretär
guterres hatte dazu bereits mehrfach
aufgerufen
johannes hano in new york guten abend
was steckt denn dahinter wie begründen
die amerikaner ihre entscheidung also
eine offizielle begründung gibt es nicht
aber es zeigt einmal mehr dass die un
sicherheitsrat zum spielball
egoistischer nationaler interessen
gewordenes vor sieben wochen hat der
un-generalsekretär schon aufgefordert zu
einer internationalen waffenruhe
der sicherheitsrat hat das einfach
liegen lassen hat sich nicht weiter
damit beschäftigt erst auf drängen
deutschlands hat man sich dann im april
mit der sache beschäftigt und dann haben
die chinesen aber gesagt okay wir machen
das aber nur wenn wir auch die rolle der
weltgesundheitsorganisation bei der
bekämpfung der krise mit aufnehmen
wohl wissend dass die amerikaner das
ablehnen werden denn donald trump steht
das wasser bei der bekämpfung hier bis
zum hals und er macht die
weltgesundheitsorganisation und china
für diese ganze krise überhaupt erst
verantwortlich
die franzosen und dann versucht einen
kompromiss vorschlag einzureichen habe
gesagt okay wir verzichten auf die whu
und sagen einfach nur alle relevanten un
organisationen sollen unterstützt werden
das sah dann für einen moment so aus als
könnte man sich darauf einigen und dann
kam jetzt das nein der amerikaner ein
scherbenhaufen viele diplomaten ist
völlig frustriert sagen der
sicherheitsrat muss reformiert werden
denn wenn man schon angesichts der
größten krise der menschheit seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg nicht in der lage ist
sich auf einen minimalkonsens zu einigen
dann versinkt der sicherheitsrat langsam
in der bedeutungslosigkeit
vielen dank für ihre aufklärung der
hintergründe johannes hano in new york
und jetzt zu einem runden geburtstag der
europäische gedanke wird heute 70 jahre
alt
denn genau am 9 mai 1950 überraschte der
französische außenminister robert
schuman die welt mit einem plan
frankreich und deutschland könnten doch
ihre kohle- und stahlindustrie
zusammenlegen
ausgerechnet die beiden erzfeinde gerade
einmal fünf jahre nach kriegsende
kanzler adenauer sagte sofort ja
und der plan ging in die geschichte ein
als grundstein für die spätere
europäische union heute blickte die eu
zurück so gut und feierlich wie es eben
geht in corona zeiten in bonn statt
volksfest zum europatag wird diesmal nur
die flagge gehisst vereint solle man
gegen das corona virus vorgehen denn
gemeinsam sei man stärker mahnt die eu
kommission auf dem platz der nach robert
schumann benannt wurde
der hatte eben jene einigkeit schon vor
70 jahren gefordert fünf jahre nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg es ist also möglich
auch nach großen krisen solidarität zu
wagen
solidarität zeigt das europaparlament
seit wochen schon wird in den kantinen
küchen gekocht für bedürftige und
hilfsorganisationen der viele
bürogebäude derzeit ungenutzt sind
konnten hier 100 frauen einziehen die
sonst auf der straße leben und manchmal
ein obdachlosenheim unterkommen dort
wohnen wir oft mit drei bis zehn leuten
in einem raum sagt diese frau die nicht
erkannt werden will
hier haben wir plötzlich eine
privatsphäre jede frau hat ihr eigenes
zimmer bei den sanitäranlagen musste
nachgebessert werden denn duschen gab es
im bürogebäude nicht in einer zeit die
für viele so negativ ist haben wir
einigen mit dieser aktion eine atempause
gegönnt solidarität haben die
gründerväter einst gefordert mehr denn
je ist sie wichtig für den erhalt der
europäischen union über auftritte mit
weißen tigern machten das magier duo
siegfried und roy weltberühmt nun ist
roy horn an den folgen einer corona
infektion gestorben
er wurde 75 jahre
millionen fans sahen die shows der
beiden deutschen in las vegas bis 2003
als einer der tiger auf der bühne
angriff und schwerverletzte
die welt habe einen großen magier
verloren erklärte siegfried heute er
selbst seinen besten freund und wir
müssen abschied nehmen von einem
weiteren ganz großen little richard
superstar mit 87 ist der erfinder des
rock'n'roll gestorben
christoph distel erinnert an den sänger
der sich mit einem einzigen schrei
unsterblich macht so klingt ein
meilenstein ganz gut sei das lied vorher
gewesen erinnert sich mitstreiter dann
mitten in den aufnahmen sei ritschard
spontan damit gekommen der urschrei des
rock'n'roll
[Musik]
gitarre dafür sein klavier und seine art
toupiert geschminkt achtung anfang der
50er war das vater schmuggler sehr arm
er selbst ja wirklich erst einmal
tellerwäscher und dann star aus dem
nichts mit riesenerfolg und einer prise
selbstbewusstsein aber auch das war er
homosexuell dabei streng religiös
zweimal brachte richard seine karriere
ab wollte priester werden kam zurück und
plötzlich war er zur legende geworden
übrigens 17 70 groß kein problem das er
später keine kids mehr schrieb fand bob
dylan hiermit sei doch eigentlich alles
gesagt
immer noch mitreißend das wetter morgen
zunächst wenige schauer und gewitter die
am nachmittag aber durchaus heftig
werden können mehr hat gleich katja
horneffer so viel von uns claus kleber
und das heute journal um viertel vor elf
und nach einem monat pause freut sich
dann um 23 uhr jochen breyer im
aktuellen sportstudio auf sie wir sind
morgen abend wieder für sie da punkt 7
einen entspannten abend noch für sie
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
morgen kämpfen sommer und winter
gegeneinander
der sommer kommt hier aus dem süden mit
dem tief ag und dem hoch paul kommt mit
südwestlicher strömung wirklich wärme zu
uns und der winter kommt mit hochgenuss
und tief britta denn dieses tief bringt
uns doch tatsächlich nochmal
schneewolken bis in unsere richtung noch
nicht gleich morgen aber spätestens am
montag pünktlich zu den eisheiligen sind
diese schneewolken dann da der reihe
nach heute nacht gibt es einige
regenschauer hier im westen oder auch am
alpenrand sonst ist es häufig klar und
das wird eine wilde nacht bei 14 bis 6
grad und morgen vormittag beginnt es
dann in der atmosphäre zu brodeln es
gibt die ersten regenschauer und
gewitter anders sieht das sie sich der
donau aus und auch hier zwischen der
ostseeküste und der lausitz da strahlt
nämlich die soll im laufe des
nachmittags ziehen die regenschauer und
gewitter weiter in richtung norden und
osten und in den mittelgebirgen kann es
noch unwetter geben also gewitter die
mit hagel starkregen und sturmböen
verbunden sind an der nordseeküste
dagegen der macht sich schon der
nordwind bemerkbar da bleibt es kühl mit
nur 15 grad sonst werden nochmal fast
sommerlich jetzt 20 bis 27 grad erreicht
der wetter und temperatursturz der macht
sich dann am montag bemerkbar da kann es
bis auf 6 700 meter unter schneien
schönes wochenende